okay so many things about this we're
talking about Joe Biden Breakfast Club
interview is really just Joe Biden and
Charlamagne
Allen was great and a phenomenal and
Charlemagne at the end of the video Joe
Biden goes you knows listen if you're
having trouble to decide in between
Trump or me before that Charlemagne is
saying we need to talk more because I
want to know what you're gonna do for
our community before I decide who to
vote for a lot of time left before
November so we gotta have more talks
right and then and then biingo's listen
if you're having trouble deciding
between Trump or me then you ain't black
and he smiles he's obviously joking
around etc black Twitter goes crazy the
black voting for free how dare you say
this what do what does Biden think we
are you think we're completely loyal to
this literally a month ago did he got
cancelled for saying the exact same [ __ ]
oh yeah that's it director hold on okay
so did he literally goes yo the black
vote ain't for free and people are like
how could you vote Republican Diddy who
the [ __ ] do you think you are what are
you thinking why would you vote for them
Joe Biden just repeats the same thing
that people say on black Twitter every
single day they criticize the [ __ ] out
of Kanye for vote Trump they criticize
the [ __ ] out of anybody who ever said
that they would consider voting Trump
and by them just echoes those same
sentiments and all the sudden black
turned into like this rational swing
state where it's like well I'm gonna
vote whoever does the best thing for me
it said it was too funny I didn't tweet
that though and then tweet them back i
but i so are you gonna consider a voting
Republican there immediately if you like
to [ __ ] nah man so it was so funny man
Layton I love it but van gogh's that was
completely inappropriate there's so
substitute like this he goes I was
completely inappropriate with what what
Biden said was completely inappropriate
disrespectful that being said I'm still
fooling blue it doesn't matter it's like
come on bro y'all with Knicks fans like
I hate when they stad that line at the
end is like because they don't want to
look like sellouts everybody's afraid of
looking like we're all afraid of the mob
yeah but the real is just that one line
that people had a problem with
like don't tell us you're not black if
you own vote for me like that's wild so
oh that's oh listen like everything else
he said warranted a hundred percent who
left that line out he would have been
he's gonna do that all the time I know
it's gonna be so good it's gonna be
hilarious honestly if I was him I would
not have apologized if I was body not
big I stand by that a hundred percent if
you don't think that I'm gonna do more
for black people than this guy then you
don't care about black blue or black
being black is not at the beginning of
your identity is not a core value that
you care about I would double down on
that [ __ ] a hundred percent tell you you
wouldn't got it liked it I mean I'm
gonna be the nominee yeah I don't know
what are you gonna vote for Trump like
is there anything Biden could say on
that level that's like you ain't black
this sudden we're between a rock and a
hard place but we don't have anybody
good we want to vote for we elected the
hard place and the rock so like what you
want to do you know I mean yeah these
are people people voted for so here's
the thing here's a I thought that the
interview from Charla was genius because
I think he guaranteed a black Vice
President nominee guaranteed now they
have to it's got to be Kamala if she
turns it down maybe it's someone else
but there's no way it can be not a
person of course gonna be Klobuchar or
whatever her name is I think oh that's
out apparently I was very close yang for
this done done because if they don't do
it then black people confront like
they're gonna vote for Trump now I've
been saying I'm brilliant idiots for
maybe the past five years and I've
gotten tons of heat and eventually
people start to like understand it but
the conversations I've been having with
Charlemagne and the things that
Charlemagne's main is starting to saying
now have been echoing these sentiments
which is you cannot possibly get
something from somebody politically
speaking if they care if they already
feel like they have your vote guaranteed
yeah all of your leverage is not
guaranteeing your vote if you notice
Obama doesn't co-sign the fro bomber
doesn't cosign any candidate till he
knows who won the primary but Biden was
his guy Obama didn't say a peep until
Biden wins the primary he is the
Democrat
nominee now Obama's like okay I got you
right it's like you need to make sure
that you can play and position yourself
with your leverage if all black people
like you know we might [ __ ] with Trump
what do you got for us you got a bill
you got a strategy guaranteed right now
Trump and his team are working on a
black strategy guarantee I mean they've
been doing that
no no but like a specific point of black
strategy to put their foot on Biden's
[ __ ] neck and that would actually
crush it to be honest if they came out
right now with a phenomenal black
strategy that the black elites really
believed in and thought could work I
guarantee you could see a switch I
guarantee it
this is an unprecedented time I think
what we really should take away from
this is that we're gonna get a black
vice president thanks to Andrew that's
what I think I think that's the point I
noticed and listen yo can I tell you
something let's say Biden wins right
yeah Biden's probably gonna die or at
least become senile okay he'll be
removed first female full what full
black what first full black president
full black if Biden vice president dies
but come all right Brenda Oh II think
yeah so it's close on a mother should
ever know apparently Kamala was getting
stroked my famous dudes back in the day
like she's kind of cool she was like
[ __ ] Montell Jordan she's a [ __ ] a
few other famous disco yeah like she's
kind of cool with it
Blanco she wanted that power spot you
know she'll kill Biden a hundred percent
like that well you mean like nagging
maybe even a vice president has a wild
idea yeah what do you mean I don't got
enough women talking to me tell me what
to do row all the fotomat yeah nah dude
for a second I thought that's what the
president's wife was I totally forgot in
that little moment of time I totally
forgot that pence was there and I was
like
and always a female yo real talk that's
what the vice-president should be just
the white oh yeah and then you could
divorce that [ __ ] out of a vitamin she
brings up [ __ ] do you want to be a
nice-looking ex vice president real
quick she probably still keep the White
House though he's gonna house
it is interesting we'll see what happens
but I I look I love it you know me I'm
gonna point out hypocrisy where I see it
but I love the fact that black people
are starting to publicly recognize the
power of their vote and are willing to
leverage that into progress because that
is what most tight-knit communities do
and they do it on a local level because
usually they don't have the numbers to
influence a national election right but
like the Chinese community in Chinatown
I'm sure will do whatever they can to
like get you know congressman or what is
it called like state assemblyman or
whatever hired in their area to serve
their interests black people should do
that [ __ ] just like everybody else i
100% think every minority is perfectly
it's great when they support themselves
and they are all about themselves and
support their own businesses and all
that and a black people realize I can
swing an election like this might be the
first step to being like oh we should
just do everything I'll take over
real talk real talk think about how much
political leverage black people would
have if you swung the election for Trump
think about how much political leverage
by people have if they all decide to
vote Trump this election and Trump wins
by that percentage point and they fully
were like listen we're just going to the
highest bidder right not to bring it
back to that
different different it's not so bad
powering so but like realistically think
about that like imagine do how right now
like Wisconsin and what are the other
two Ohio yeah they're like certain
states the swing states in America have
massive political leverage right and
presidents will go visit and stump in
these small states that really I don't
want to say are insignificant but have
far less significance economically yep
then New York or California or Texas or
something like that right but presidents
will go there and beg for their votes
black people could potentially be that
yep
imagine that you would have every
[ __ ] president tap-dancing all these
little white guys tap-dancing for you
guys for your [ __ ] new your swing if
you do black people is sweet oh yeah I
think that's a problem they don't know
that we're willing to swing but right
now is that because you're not I know
that's true
that's why I'm saying it it's true but
I'm saying do it they already Tantra
vote so they're already tap dance right
they don't throw right Mary yeah come on
it like in South Carolina they were
shucking and jiving you got that guy
dance it the [ __ ] juvenile back that
ass up you had Biden he was like his
whole hey maybe if you don't vote for
Trump you ain't black maybe that's the
black move his own for Trump swing that
election yo real talk bro yeah but the
funniest thing that people who didn't
missed in that interview Charla axe I'm
about like his black agenda and he's
like yeah you haven't seen my black
agenda the black manifesto and he called
it the guy act manifest got a name of
his black agenda rogue it's called lift
every voice he calls it the black man
like nobody called that that's so I mean
I don't think anybody knew what the [ __ ]
is black agenda was yeah and what was
his black agenda and look here's the
reality some Vegas black agenda is gonna
be good enough because you don't want
you don't know why is because who said
the forty acres and a mule thing back in
the day
first of all let's be honest hahahaha
day that would have been a lot of black
people talking about I want the 40 acres
and a mule figuratively
y'all know it's doing the mule
you know y'all go to view the mules
Pinto you like that instead of a mule
okay you gonna make one ox tail you
gonna call you gonna call Kamala Harris
Jamaican ass over like you know how we
cook up this mule baby done you give us
all meal the next milk every white
person gonna be drinking as let's be
honest forty acres in a mule duck I mean
one mule for 40 acres what yeah that's
actually that was a raw deal back then
how you gonna get one mule to go over 40
acres forming in there like that just
get one mule they will handle this we
have 40 acres and a mule yeah I guess on
that's an amazing deal bro yeah we still
weigh in but who said no to it what
happened was they're like you didn't
just didn't give it are you sure yes yes
that's why we're a brilliant white
people our marketing wise is they
promise that and never gave it and then
if you do that to somebody else you're
called an Indian giver how the [ __ ] but
not a white gift son where you think we
learned it from and [ __ ] Indians
broke
[Applause]